Let's pray together as we seek the Lord
for the holiness that separates us from the common or the ordinary.
Father, we come into your holy presence, and we give thanks to you
for your great grace.
You've been so good to us. We couldn't begin to thank or
list every single blessing.
But Lord, the overwhelming bounty of your
goodness to us
just makes us rejoice. Nothing we have is
from our own skill, our own ability, our own right arm
cannot save us. We thank you, Lord, that you have blessed us
with all things that we need for life and godliness.
But Lord,
so many things in our lives, so many times,
we just depend upon our own strength, and we treat everything in our
life, we just assume that it's ours.
We assume that everything we have belongs to
us. Oh God, open our eyes and help us
to see that there is nothing in the world, there is
nothing in our lives, there's nothing in our family or our possessions or our
time or our talents or our treasure that doesn't
belong to you. So oh God, open our
eyes. Open our minds to see everything
like you see it in our lives. Oh God, would you help us to
place willingly everything under the Lordship of Jesus
Christ. If there's anything that we're not seeing clearly, that we're
seeing as ordinary or common, oh God, would
you help us to see it as holy? I pray, Lord, that you reveal
things even now to me and to my prayer partner.
Would you open our eyes to see what is really holy, to see
what holiness is really like, and let us take
everything that we once thought was common and realize it is
dedicated, it must be dedicated to you.
Thank you, Lord, for taking all those things and making them holy.
We pray that you'd bless us with the knowledge of your holiness and how to live it
out. In Jesus' name.
Let's continue seeking and praying together.